welcome to CBS this morning we're going
to use our real names today Jo Anthony
and Tony we'll begin with this a meeting
that's going on right now could decide
the future of US allies in Syria and the
US has no part in it a ceasefire in
northern Syria is due to expire later
today
it's also the deadline for Kurdish
forces to withdraw from the area his
Turkish troops move in if the fighting
resumes curbs who helped the u.s. fight
Isis will be at risk along with many
civilian turkeys president just began
talks with Russian President Putin to
discuss Syria's future
Holly Williams is in southern Turkey
near the Syrian border Holly good
morning what can we expect as this
fragile ceasefire runs out good morning
well Turkey's president read Jeb Tayyip
Erdogan has threatened to quote crush
the heads of Kurdish LED forces if they
don't fully withdraw from the
turkey-syria border by tonight when that
ceasefire runs out so the stakes are
very high as president Irwin meets with
Russian President Vladimir Putin the
future of eastern Syria could be decided
at their meeting today
Russia's poised to step into the power
vacuum the u.s. left behind when
President Trump ordered US troops to
leave eastern Syria earlier this month
he effectively opened the door to a
deadly Turkish offensive those US troops
only numbered around a thousand but with
their Kurdish partners they were able to
beat back Isis and bring relative
stability to around a third of Syria
thousands of those Kurdish LED fighters
died battling against Isis now they say
they've been betrayed by America around
200,000 civilians have reportedly fled
the clashes with Turkey but Turkey says
it isn't targeting civilians and views
the Kurdish led forces as a terrorist
group President Trump said yesterday
that quote we never agreed to protect
the Kurds for the rest of their lives
Anthony Holly Williams near the
turkey-syria border Thank You Holly